let's jump to this uh good fun story we
have here from the new york post kathy
griffin slammed for saying republicans
will start a civil war the first thing i
want to say is she stole your line no no
your post is wrong hold on new york post
you need to issue a correction she did
not say republicans will start a civil
war she never said that that is
defamation and slander of our good
friend keith
what she said was if you don't want a
civil war vote for democrats in november
if you do want civil war vote republican
she did not say in any capacity the
republicans would start one in fact she
didn't she didn't in any way imply
either well she didn't state either side
would but she implied democrats would
let's do some basic logic real quick
if you vote for democrats
they win
there won't be a civil war that means
republicans will do nothing
if you vote for republicans and they win
and she says there will be a civil war
in that capacity well republicans aren't
going to start a civil war after winning
legitimate power yeah the democrats
would have to start fighting with them
otherwise they're in power she's
actually implying democrats will start a
civil war many people pointed this out
she's basically issuing a threat yep if
you don't vote for us we are going to
war well and twitter's cool with it
civil war yeah leave it up
this is the second one she did the cut
the the trump head i think it's and it
held that bloody head this is kind of
another weird like uh visceral
statement it's just shock value i think
after that trump head thing she should
just went you know what no more no more
internet for me yeah i think i'm done
yeah take her phone away seriously i saw
her try to work it back and say you know
if the democrats are in power they'll be
able to hold off the maga republicans
from starting some sort of war that's
what i meant by the tweet but i don't
think that
so he so she's implying that the the
maga republicans get elected are handed
the keys to the castle and then they're
gonna go and just start running around
and smashing things
they have legitimate power they've won
an election why would they do anything
like that they're all crazy white people
tim we don't know what they're gonna do
i don't know what white people are well
that's true but then you end up with
people like tim scott they act like
doesn't exist you know what i mean
yeah i wonder how much of of kathy is
getting taken out of context because
it's did she say this verbally or was
this in text it's a tweet
oh she's a comedian texting your jokes
don't always translate to attack come on
i don't think this is a joke i mean
it does seem like a cry for attention
she didn't have that reality tv show it
was like uh my life as a d-list
celebrity or something oh yeah yeah this
is way back in the deal of celebrities
i've never heard of it so herself you
know she really does need people to
notice her whenever whenever possible so
i feel like again she's somewhat
political openly a lot of the time but
also you know she has to stay part of
the relevant conversation as somebody
who who's you know half of their tweets
are completely nonsensical and hilarious
uh yes i'm saying my jokes are funny
i feel for kathy griffin if she's taken
out of context the only issue is she
made she took a photo of herself holding
a
faux severed head of donald trump it's
hard to get out of context yeah she's
she's literal like you know look i think
my tweets are funny because i'm
intentionally trolling and screwing
around and the fact that some people
believe so i'll tell you this i tweeted
when the left was ragging on the song we
put out i said the success of only ever
wanted proves that deep down americans
crave powerful emo
but the music
corporate elite are conspiring to
suppress it
and they started they started sharing
the tweet on reddit another post being
like tim poole literally thinks this and
i'm like that was so overt
and it's nonsense
that no sane person would believe i was
being telling the truth if you were to
look at kathy griffin as saying and you
think she's joking then i think you're
being equally dishonest i think this is
the this year's democrats get out the
vote campaign like if you don't vote for
us it's going to end in civil war and
they want you to believe it's
republicans but as soon as completely
right and pointing out it's actually the
democrats being like we will riot we've
been doing it for a little while here
everyone's cool when we do it not when
any republicans do it you know it's it's
kind of crazy that she can post this it
can stay up and she's going to be like
no i'm in the right to say it this is a
get out the vote it's all fear tactics i
mean she seems clearly inspired by joe
biden we watched his last speech where
he's talking about you know the maga
republicans are the threat to america so
we all have to worry about they hate
this country so long as they don't win i
think they're really just pushing fear
fear fear and please get out and vote
for us or else and it works
yep
it it works and you know
a lot of republicans are like oh it's
going to be a red tsunami we're going to
win and i'm like yeah you better operate
under the assumption it's going to be a
blue wave and get out every single
person you can because i'll tell you
even if you do win the likelihood the
republicans you know the republican
leadership will do something is low so
you need to make sure the win is
overwhelming so that yeah look if if in
swing states you get moderate
republicans who win then they're going
to jam things up and be like no no now
listen you know we got to be we can't
play that way we have rick santorum and
you know i respect the guy but he was
like we can't play that game we got to
play by the rules and i'm like oh okay
like dude i get it play by the rules but
playing by the rules also means you
subpoena them when they do something
illegal you don't say well you know
that's too much and too far well that's
what they're doing they're going after
trump they're going after bannon they're
going after people on the right they put
peter navarro in shackles so maybe
republicans need to win and just you
know get some subpoenas and do some
investigations figure out what went on
with with crossfire hurricane maybe get
some accountability for russiagate yeah
and i think if you are a conservative
leaning voter it's much better to look
at the tsunami after it's hit then yeah
like i think it's coming yes i'll just
pretend like and then it turns out it's
nothing yeah there is i think the
republican party is prone to complacency
and you know they think they're being
forgiving being like well we're not
going to follow up on any of these
things we could press charges but you
know we're going to be the bigger people
and move on and it's like no actually
you are letting the justice system fall
by the wayside by being inactive and
becoming complacent yeah the riots of
2020 was example of that like day two
where was the national guard all they
said was like well if we if we start
prosecuting people we'll probably get
worse right we're being mean we're just
reactionary and just reactive we're like
waiting for them to come to our backyard
to react to them and then going oh well
there was no laws to protect me for this
oh so sorry
so i get called a black pillar a lot
because i'm constantly like hey guys i'm
i'm not convinced there's going to be a
red wave and they're like oh just let it
happen i'm like no you can't do that way
you need to be taking every single
possible step you can you need to be
getting other people involved in voting
and i've been going back and forth a lot
of people about whether we should fight
on their level and i think the ultimate
answer is that yes we should as far as
law fair goes and then as far as like
character goes we need to stick by see
that's where your conservative
principles can actually come out is in
your character you don't need to do what
they do you don't need to cancel people
as hard as they do but you can fight
back on the level playing ground that is
supposedly there was a pull from the
trafalgar group i think today that said
after biden's speech
uh a lot of independence and i can't
remember the percentage but let's say 30
percent swung and we're like this that's
speechless that's like cool aggressive
rhetoric this is uh inappropriate like
this is not right obviously you know
high percentage of democrats thought
that speech was wonderful lots of
conservatives were like wait no that's
insane but it was the independents who
were like you're losing us here joe
biden administration the democrat
democratic party like this is not
something that we support i think it was
like uh i should wish i had the number
in front of me like fifty percent were
like there's a lot yeah over here like
we are against how this presentation and
the way this looks i think in some ways
the democrats themselves will show are
showing their true colors but i can't
stress enough that i feel like the
republican party's one of their biggest
issues is that they become complacent
and they're like got in the bag let's
all just pack up and go home and that's
how you lose no we need serious
asymmetric uh what would you call it i
guess culture warfare is a culture well
law fair i'm open to being equal we
should be treating the law equally among
all people but if you want to win a
culture war against a communist infusion
or whatever the hell is happening you
need deep spiritual power you need some
sort of imbalance of power to win that
and that i think is internal it's it's
meditation consciousness uh listening to
people
yeah being willing to cry
that comes out the way that we
communicate is so different to the way
that progressives communicate and i've
learned that a lot just being having
worked on both sides their grassroots
organizing endeavors are insane and
they're very well run they're they're in
the communities running around knocking
doors having conversations with people
and having very emotional conversations
with people and i think that's what
influences voters conservatives we're
not very emotional
we don't use like a storyline in order
to influence people and as far as his
speech he had an amazing opportunity to
hop up there and give a message of unity
and say you know we can co-exist there
is a way that we can unite out of this
and i want to be the president who does
that but he fumbled the ball and at
least that ball is now in our court yeah
i think the play was you're gonna fumble
the other team's gonna but then we're
gonna recover it and run it in for a
touch like it was like in the the speech
was written as a fumble see i feel like
it wasn't actually about unity because
of the lines about the right-wing
extreme he was like under the guise of
patriotism being like look i'm in front
of independence hall and they've got all
these great colors and look at those
marines and then it's like but remember
the moderate conservatives are the devil
and if you vote for them you are going
to set our country on fire the emotions
it's not a unifying message the emotion
thing is everything yes right now the
democrats are heavily just targeting
emotions hate and fear hate and fear and
i think people on the right as you were
mentioning they're not very emotional
they don't get it ben shapiro you know
thinks he'll make a logical argument and
convince convince you but in fact he's
only speaking people who are already
logical and people who are already
logical are probably already more
right-leaning
so i know this from having done uh
street fundraising and i'm canvassing
where we would go and talk to people on
the street wave hi
they always give you these spiels and
they would be like say this and they
were very methodic logical hi my name is
this i work for here here's the problem
we face here's how you can help right of
course that stuff never works
and they don't want you to say anything
else like for like legal reasons but i
was like dude i can get people to sign
up for anything without saying a single
fact like they're worried about you
saying something factually incorrect and
then giving someone someone gives a
donation and then you've got like a you
know liability issue or something and
i'm like just tug on their heartstrings
just you know so the pitches i would do
were often very much like trying to make
people cry
just like tell them a story about uh you
know
talking about homeless people telling
them a story about a homeless person
that no one loves
imagine what it must feel like that no
one's there for you and no one loves you
and then when you finally do see someone
walking on the street they look at you
with disgust and they spit on you
and then people are like feeling bad and
then they they donate the best sales
pitch i've ever seen was this guy
selling
door-to-door children's encyclopedias
who was like yeah i took this
opportunity to be out here because my
fiance is here but you know it's really
hard and they didn't tell you that our
wages would be awful and we have to buy
the product first and like we like i'll
have to share a van and like i have to
sell these because otherwise i'm in debt
to the company and like i watched so
many people buy that guy's encyclopedia
he might as well been selling i don't
even know what but if you if you go up
to somebody and say
he also may not have had a fiance i just
want to put that on table no idea he
could have been lying the whole thing
could have been a lie the the same is
true for for the right like if you were
gonna make a pitch and say like here's
here's why democrat policy is bad right
joe biden he's enacted these these
policies such as banning fracking on
public lands which has caused a spike in
speculation now here's a logical reason
why that's gonna they don't care they
don't care they say you're lying they
say it's fake news donald trump is bad
he's evil you need to go out and like
drive emotions talk of you know
just create a circumstance where you
make them feel something and then point
them in the direction of what what they
that's what the democrats do they say
bad stuff bad stuff donald trump bad
stuff
our best bet is like going out there
talking about the state of the economy
right now how american families are
hurting talk about this defund the
police movement and how it's hurting
low-income minority communities tug on
the heartstrings there and it's not a
hard thing to do because it's real it's
actually happening people are seeing it
in their backyard parents are getting
galvanized because they're their
students are being affected in this
public schooling system that's
completely failing them if you use those
emotional stories and then you know plug
in the facts there as you need to uh
people will get behind you thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the tim cast irl podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
monday through friday at 8pm and we'll
see you all there